[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Securing
modern web applications
can be a challenge with an
escalating number of threats,
having to manage multiple
vendors and point products,
and an increasingly high
standard of security
expected by your customers.
Google Cloud
simplifies all of that
by giving you
comprehensive protection
through a suite of
proven Google technology,
all managed from a
single interface.
Protecting some of the most
prolific internet properties--
such as Google Search,
Gmail, and YouTube--
has led Google to develop
advanced and sophisticated
protections which you can
now leverage for your web
applications and APIs.
Implement an industry-standard
web application firewall
with granular IP and
geo-based controls
and defend against
prevalent attacks
such as denial of service,
cross-site scripting, and SQL
injection.
Protect your web app from
fraudulent activity and abuse.
With Google Cloud, you have
access to intelligent fraud
and bot detection services.
With an adaptive
risk analysis engine
assessing the needs of your
business and rich telemetry,
you can easily protect from
scraping, credential stuffing,
automated account creation, and
exploits from automated bots.
Integrations can be
another point of weakness.
With Google Cloud, you can
secure your APIs in minutes.
Out-of-the-box policies enable
developers to augment APIs with
features to control traffic,
enhance performance,
and enforce security.
Meet the challenge of securing
modern web applications
with Google Cloud's Web
App and API Protection.
If you want to learn more about
this solution, watch a webinar,
or read a white paper,
go to g.co/cloud/waap.